hey folks if you'd like to support me or
this channel move university in creating
more video tutorials then please
consider making a financial contribution
at my website booth university I found
thanks and enjoy the video okay so in
this video I want to discuss membrane
lipids and introduce them and so so what
is a membrane lipid a membrane lipid we
know that there lipids that make up
membranes that should be pretty
intuitive right membrane lipids what
else could they be right so what are
they though what do they contain they're
basically they contain a polar head
group a polar head group so that's one
portion and then they have a hydrophobic
tail or a nonpolar tail okay so that's
kind of what I've drawn here so this is
like a little representation of what a
membrane lipid should contain it should
contain a polar head group and a
nonpolar tail so that it can make up a
membrane now all of these membrane
lipids that we'll talk about are
amphipathic or amphiphilic which of
course MV philic which means they
contain both polar or or hydrophilic and
nonpolar or hydrophobic portions okay
now so membrane lipids they can actually
be divided in a variety of ways but I've
just divided it up like this so membrane
lipids I divided them up here as but you
can have phospholipids or you could have
glycol lipids so phospholipids contain a
phosphate group whereas glycol lipids
contain a carbohydrate portion glyco of
course refers to something like glycogen
right sugar so it contains egg like oops
not ocean portion contains a
carbohydrate portion so now once you
have a phospholipid you can classify
there's two types right you can have a
glycerophospholipid or you can have a
sphingolipid or a single phospholipid or
a phospho sphingolipid
so let's look at those now what is the
glycerophospholipid well it's got a
backbone the backbone is glycerol and
that should make sense given the name
right glycerophospholipid phospholipid
because as a phosphate group and that's
shown down here in the red portion and
the glycerol refers to the glycerol
backbone the rest of it is not too
complex the glycerol backbone is what we
have here if a phosphate group is part
of the polar head group the rest of the
polar head group has some alcohol
attached to that phosphate group the
other two groups attached to the other
two carbons of glycerol are just fatty
acid groups okay so that's the general
sort of structure or sort of what a
glycerophospholipid might look like so
it's a phospholipid because it contains
this phosphate glycerol because it has
this glycerol backbone and of course
it's membrane lipid because it has this
polar portion with the phosphate and
alcohol and the nonpolar portion with
the fatty acid tails now a phospholipid
that's a sphingolipid the difference
really is is pretty much that that
instead of having a glycerol backbone as
a sphingo spin back alone and the
sphingosine backbone kind of loops
around right okay it goes up and goes
around like this so we don't have room
for two fatty acid tails we'll just have
one here okay
even though though the the sphingosine
kind of like the backbone itself kind of
has pretty much a fatty acid tail it's
got a hydrocarbon tail that that sort of
takes up the space where the fatty acid
would have been in the Kalista row with
the glycerol backbone and of course the
the the polar head group is a phosphate
group attached to some alcohol so both
of these are phospholipids because they
have phosphates in their polar head
groups and the only difference really is
the the backbone and the backbone is the
root difference for whether or not we
have two or one fatty acid actually
attached to the backbone so that's
phospholipids now over here glyco lipids
they contain a carbohydrate portion so
that's going to be their polar head
group so there can be glycosphingolipids
or spin gold i clip isn't
I mean I'm either way the name
make sense I'm not really sure exactly
how you break it down but point is that
the the sphingolipids would have a
sphingosine backbone they'd have that
one fatty acid but their polar head
group would be some carbohydrate portion
right now galacto lipids Galacta lipids
are a little bit different than
sphingolipid lipid but better that are
classified under glycolipids these have
a glycerol backbone two fatty acid tails
and then a carbohydrate portion
okay now Galacta lipids um could
actually have you notice I've drawn a
little dotted line coming out of this
carbohydrate portion here and that's
because you can attach a sulfate group
there and if a sulfate group is attached
to the carbohydrate portion on a
Galactic what you have is a cellphone
lipid okay so this was just a sort of
overview of the membrane lipids I hope
that video was helpful in introducing
them thank you for watching yo if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
Like comment subscribe for more content
and if you know anybody you might find
the videos helpful then please share
with them Thanks happy studying